probably you know subconsciously and
makes us feel like when's it enough
nothing like a little sisterly
competition am i right yeah well it's
not so fun when your little sister is a
billionaire Kylie Jenner during a stop
by the real Kourtney Kardashian got
candid about feeling pressure to succeed
after Forbes dubbed Kylie the youngest
self-made billionaire in 2018 I think
that's a thing I always think to myself
you know when is it enough because I
don't like missing out on certain things
you know like doing making homework or
certain after-school activities but this
isn't the first time she's weighed in on
her babysitter's billionaire status in a
June episode of Keeping Up with the
Kardashians
Kourtney through some serious shade at
Kylie dam if I were you Kourt I'd be
nice to Kylie billionaire Jenner because
she's well you said it a freakin
billionaire when et caught up with Chris
Kendall and Kim following Kylie's Forbes
cover they were a little bit nicer about
the 22 year olds high honor she works
really hard she made her own money for
over a decade she put it in the bank
she saved every nickel and then when she
decided she really you know decided on
what she wanted to do she spent her
money on a venture that could have gone
south or north and it did really well
not like that was handed to her she
figured that all out okay but back to
court on the real when she was asked
whether or not she anticipated her
family's success back when they were
first starting out she gave that a hard
knew we didn't even think about it like
we just kind of hit the ground running
and just I don't even know if that's the
right thing like just we just you know
kind of did it and it happened so
quickly and I don't think we even
thought about it and she didn't exactly
shut down the rumor said she might quit
the show in the very near future
there's a rumor that you might be
leaving the Kardashians show so I mean
every day is different
oh so you actually considered it yeah
but I at the current moment I'm happy
and it can bury into my blessings okay I
definitely you know have my moments no
don't do it Kourtney if you leave who's
gonna give us sound bite goals like this
born [ __ ] and this Amy who when easy
caught up with Ryan Seacrest who is one
of the reality shows executive producers
he gave his two cents about Kourtney
wanting to leave the show honestly I
don't know how they do it they've lived
for over a decade with cameras following
I could not do it and no matter what
they were paying them I couldn't do it
so I give them a lot of credit from
those cameras in their lives all the
time and I love you Courtney well the
good news is that there are about a
billion members of the kardashian-jenner
family
so if Kourt does leave the show there
will still be a plenty o drama from born
[ __ ] and something tells me it'll be a
long time before this family hangs up
their reality TV hats and we'll be right
here to keep you up with the Kardashians
so make sure to keep it locked right
here on e t until next time I'm Holly
Stephens bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]